the book rogers reboot looks like it's
back on track welcome to sidetrack your
sci-fi tv movie channel
[Music]
so i did a video a few months ago about
how we were looking at getting a book
rogers reboot but that reboot was in
danger because there was basically two
warring parties wanting to do this
project and well one was going to sue
the other well that legal quagmire has
been cleared up now and
smokehouse productions in cooperation
with legendary pictures have now got a
clear run at making the book rogers
movie smokers production is actually
owned by george clooney so we could see
buck rogers played by
george potentially which is a really
exciting thing because actually i'm a
big fan of george clooney i think he's
got that cheeky glitter that actually
could really work um as the character
book rogers um but what type of film
will we actually get to see
well i don't think it's going to be a
remake of the glennae larson project i
don't think we're going to see twiki
or uh you know spaceships and aliens and
things i think we're looking at a
project that's going to be more like the
original comic book
now this is where the legal mess kind of
came from philip nolan wrote the
original book or the original novella
um armageddon 24 19.
his family the family that owned the
estate and owned that was basically
suing um smokehouse productions to say
uh they actually issued a cease and
desist order to say you can't do this
and they had their own project with
another production agency they were
going to make theirs
that has now been dealt with and they've
said that now actually the book rogers
is not technically owned by the nolan
family because well his character is
named anthony to begin with the project
that smokehouse productions is more
based around the comic book that
followed the novella rather than the
velar itself so they're going to be able
to push forward with that and the no
nolan family basically don't have rights
to the book roger's name but hey you
never know we might get to see anthony
rogers instead now straight off i think
this is a terrible shame i'd have loved
to have seen something that was more
closely related to the glennae larsen
version because the starfighter or the
thunder fighter however you want to call
it depending on which sauce you go
through was a great sci-fi ship and i
would love to see that fighter return
it's one of those ships that's really
iconic you know it's like doing
battlestar galactica without the ships
from there you know or star trek without
the enterprise it just wouldn't work and
you know i really would have loved to
have seen that but we're not going to
see that the storyline we're going to
see is far more related to the comic
book which is book rogers goes down into
a mine there's some radioactive gas and
radiation back in the 50s could do
anything it was magic um i'm sure
they'll have to change that part of the
story because obviously it doesn't make
any sense nowadays but um he then got
frozen for 500 years and wakes up to
have an america that has been destroyed
following a war with europe that
weakened the american nation and then
gangs took over in the comic books book
rogers character used his knowledge from
fighting world war one and taught the
american freedom fighters how to fight
back against these gangs this almost
feels more like mad max really than book
rogers to me because i grew up with the
jill gerard and you know the the glenn a
larsen version but i still think it'd be
an interesting project
my worry
is that will it become a woke mess now
george clooney does have
certain political views you know he is
an advocate of lgbt rights as he should
be you know we need to be people should
be fight those and i really think
celebrities should use their power in
the world for good and he does george
clooney does do that he is also a big
outfit against anti-war um and human
rights to be honest the book rogers as
from the original comic books reeks of
an opportunity for george to
push his ideologies political ideology
onto the big screen
now i actually think sci-fi at its best
is woke i think it should be an
opportunity to there should be lays to
these projects where we actually learn
something that it reflects
the culture of the day it you know
should come away from it with a lesson
it should be about people wanting to do
better and you know highlighting when
things are bad you know star trek from
the 60s really hammered home that racism
was not a good idea at a time where race
in the united states was an epidemic now
you could argue it still is
so i don't have a problem with this
being woke i'm just a little bit
concerned that george might go too far
with it um and i do agree with people
when they come you know on my channel
sometimes and they say oh this is work
this is work
sometimes i disagree with them sometimes
i say no come on it's just woke isn't a
bad thing
but sometimes when it's shoved down your
throat
when it actually overtakes and becomes
more important than the story
then i would completely agree with the
people that say i don't want this i
would rather have something that was a
little more subtle
um so let's see what happens but the
exciting part of this is that
book rogers will be on the silver screen
very shortly george clooney will 100 be
executive producing and let's let's see
if he's brave enough to actually get in
front of the camera himself which let's
be honest he probably is
so i apologize about my voice i've got a
bit of a head cold
but if you are new to the channel please
ignore that like and subscribe hit the
bell notification it really helps the
channel out you can also consider
becoming a fully fledged side trekker
consider hitting the join button there's
also merchandise loads of different
t-shirts and things available at
citric.com there's a link in the
description all of these little things
that really help support the channel and
help me to keep going so as always
please stay safe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you